[Music]  all right to some developing news now we  are getting a preview today of president  joe biden's infrastructure plan it's a  two trillion dollar proposal  and contains billions for projects all  across the country  including transportation updates  drinking water infrastructure and  expanded broadband access there's also  300 billion dollars for affordable  housing  so of course the big question is who's  going to pay for this and how  the administration plans to raise the  corporate tax rate to 28 percent to fund  the project  a senior white house official said that  would cover the cost within 15 years  he believes that there's more that can  be done to make the corporate tax code  fair to reward  work not wealth to ensure that we can  invest in the future industries that are  going to help  all people in this country the president  is expected to announce  even more details of his plan in a  meeting today in pittsburgh